let's see
nothing oh you think i'm stupid what's
in the bag
what's in the bag
all the quran is in the background these
people they do it for the money they
don't care you know they don't care
about the hereafter they do for the
money open it please
okay
maybe they don't care about it here
after um what is this
who's um who carries two pounds in a big
bag like this at least carry a thousand
pounds that's mine that's yours uh guys
josiah for watching basically ali tried
to expose me again but he failed again
hopefully third time nothing
oh hopefully uh you know that doesn't
expose our sins uh but basically we're
making this video because only bro
believe it or not most of my day like
ninety percent of my day in
is spent giving people free accounts
free literature
99 percent of my day is getting emails
that's that's that's that's the work
that's what we do right so
obviously we're still going forward uh
and believe it or not i'll tell you guys
a crazy story uh subhanallah we got
introduced to the second developers
right for the quran
and they were from pakistan and the
brothers were so good they had seen some
of my videos you know with the other
work they basically gave us like a long
time to pay the fee but
even now after all this promotion all of
the people who've subscribed using it we
still have about seven thousand pounds
to bring the developers okay uh so we've
got a really special surprise for your
subscribers
and a lot of people have asked for this
but we have quote army basically for a
whole year oh yeah for just 500 pounds
okay 500 pounds no for a whole hundred
pounds
25 pounds 24.99 oh
oh yeah they can go support it and the
only reason we've kept this open there's
only going to be like maybe 120 100 200
of these right yeah and then we close it
so that we can get that development we
can pay off
the quran the app and then we can
continue in china but bro you know it's
not about it's not it's not i mean you
know of course there's money people pay
subscription but the best thing from
qurani is when you send me those
messages where the brother says i just
finished the quran and hijab says our
brother message i'm saying i've never
read so much quran in my life and i said
to anyone who hasn't tried it it's
completely free i mean the free trial
people told me make sure it charges them
after seven days but i said no so even
if you do the seventy free trial there's
no charging you won't even ask you for
call details right anyone can go try it
and the point is it's not the money or
any of that i mean if you don't have
money and you email us we give it for
free we don't even ask them they'll
probably comment underneath this video
right and um the point is that quran
comes into your daily life even if it's
one verse a day i know a brother who
does one verse a day he's done 10 hours
of quran reading since ramadan i mean
that's not huge but it's more than
majority of people do i don't even think
people do four hours of problem and of
course it's like that i prefer someone
instead of doing two three hours a day
and be exhausted and never go back to it
then do something small and the prophet
peace be upon him said allah loves these
that are done small but recognize the
most beloved
is what's regular concept even if it's
little so go to the seven day free trial
choose one verse right and then all
these haters and everyone subhanallah
brought qurani right we get these haters
and they go and try and they come back
and they become the biggest fans haters
become love
so guys go try out inshallah link is in
the description you can buy the yearly
membership now for a very limited time
in china and just like my family support
my problem
oh mr real money